[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday september 6th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
the number of severe natural disasters
is rising eastern kentucky is the
epicenter tonight of the nation's latest
extreme weather disaster at least 16
people have died in flooding that
rewrote the record brooks this morning a
wildfire burning out of control in
southern california forced evacuations
and led to the hurricane rapidly growing
in size and strength barreling through
the gulf and headed toward the u.s
tonight in the u.s over the last decade
we've seen six of the 10 most costly
atlantic hurricanes and seven of the top
10 most destructive wildfires in
california
and one of the most pressing issues for
local governments and first responders
is how to warn people who might be in
the path of destruction
modern alert technologies have flaws and
gaps but new systems are being tested to
improve them
joining us to discuss those is our
reporter jim carlton hi jim thanks for
joining me good to be here so jim tell
me about some of the technologies we use
now to get alerts and what some of their
flaws are you know there's one called
it's kind of known as opt in it's where
if you're a cell phone subscriber and
you live in sonoma county then it's on
you to
check in with your local provider and
check in you know you sign in and say
hey if there's a wildfire i want to be
alerted and so then when the wildfire
comes then you get the alert but no one
else does and
the problem with that technology is this
happened in boulder county colorado
just like last december there was a
wildfire that was just racing towards
some communities and the boulder county
emergency services only had opt-in
technology that was provided by a
company called everbridge inc and
basically the people that were opted in
got the alerts the people that weren't
opted in they didn't and only one third
of the people in boulder county actually
subscribe to that service to the opt-in
so that's a problem there's another
technology that fema has deployed in the
last few years
which
basically you don't have to opt in it
will collect every cell phone within a
cell phone towers range so and it's
called ipods it's integrated public
alert and warning system
ipaws to be technical and so they
started doing this and this is a lot
better because you don't have to opt in
and even if you're passing through and
there's a fire it will catch your cell
phone and so this has been deployed in
places like spokane washington et cetera
but it has some limitations too the
problem with this technology is that not
all phones can get those alerts it's
only once in the last few years newer
models of phones six out of ten american
phones can receive them so it's going
closer to solving the problem but we're
not there all the way so it's not about
wailing sirens we're really talking
about using cell phones to get emergency
messages out the problem is though if
you're in a place where the cell phone
tower has been burned down or destroyed
then you've got a problem and that
happened in the campfire which destroyed
paradise california a few years ago i
mean we're talking a lot about phones
obviously we're used to getting you know
messages over our phones but we do spend
time you know on the internet in other
places are there efforts to kind of
develop technologies that could alert us
using some of the other means of
communication
right exactly there's apps uh there's
also apps you can sign up for uh there's
a fema alert app which so you're in
kansas city you can sign up for tornado
learnings and alerts and it will warn
you on your computer
there's some um leading edge stuff that
is coming uh in august the department of
homeland security completed a
proof-of-concept test on a technology
that would actually
send an alert directly from a satellite
to the gps navigation system of a car so
for those few times when i'm not on my
phone there is another way to get me an
alert
yes and in fact and even kind of more
far out technology which could be really
really useful is to say you're at home
and you're in seattle and they have an
earthquake danger up there and they've
got early warning uh you know shake
alert systems and so say the alert goes
out there's been a 9.0 earthquake off
the coast of seattle god forbid then the
alert goes to your alexa there's
actually some work being done to maybe
take amazon's alexa and so have the
alert go to alexa and then alexa can
immediately send the alert to for
example your garage and till the garage
door open up and then
this is really far and even to your
tesla or other electric vehicle and also
have your self-driving car back out into
the driveway so the earthquake comes the
garage door is open your car's out you
can get out
that's very nascent
i talked to amazon and they're not
really doing that themselves there's a
local effort up in seattle where there's
a local earthquake safety advocate who's
working with some companies and
organizations to try to do that but
that's that could be huge i mean we're
talking about some of the the nascent
technology that could help us in the
future how far along is some of this
technology as you know wildfires and
hurricanes become more extreme well i
mean honestly it is a race against time
uh we're being just um hammered by
climate change now i mean we've had the
biggest hurricanes in the last 10 years
the biggest wildfires in the last 10
years but uh technology is going quickly
too so i think if you look in 10 years
we'll be a lot farther along
but i mean you know the problem is that
these disasters keep coming and they
tend to really the most vulnerable
people are really in rural areas like
paradise california i talked to a woman
who
she had a cell phone and as the campfire
was bearing down
she didn't know because she couldn't get
any alerts the cell phone towers were
down and she looked out her window and
could see like clouds of black smoke and
so she just kind of intuitively said we
need to get out of here and she got her
elderly mother out and they just kind of
barely made it out and that's the kind
of thing we want to try to avoid um and
with this new technology hopefully we
can
so sum this up for us leave the
listeners with maybe some some news they
can use if they live in a disaster zone
or they're going to one what's the best
kind of tech to prepare themselves
i would say sign up for any kind of
there's a thing called the nixel or
nixel you'll get a text alert that there
is a brush fire and then i would just
make sure you want to have the latest
model of a cell phone because that will
make sure that if you're driving to
you know from san francisco to reno
if you're going through a place where
there's a fire you don't know about it
your cell phone is going to be picked up
on the nearest tower and you're going to
get an alert that hey turn around you
need to turn around there's a fire up
there so i'd also get the apps
i have shake alert which is a cool app
i'm in san francisco and so we're
supposed to get like uh you know many
seconds of warning there's an earthquake
so i can go outside my house and not get
crushed
the fema app is a great one if you're
anywhere where there might be a disaster
i would get the fema app for sure you
need to just kind of help protect
yourself by increasing your ability to
receive alerts i talked to a woman named
jennifer gray thompson she's with a
group called after the fire usa they
it's a nonprofit that helps towns
rebuild um she survived the 2017 wine
country fires which killed more than 30
people and you know to this day i mean
now you know at that point she also had
problems with her cell communications
she has now have you know old-fashioned
two-way radios so with all the
technology we have you know like a
person like her she's still living in
fire country she keeps two-way radios to
alert her relatives nearby and and to
get alerts so so as far as we've come
we're still kind of relying on some old
stuff too all right that's some good
advice from our reporter jim carlton
thanks for joining us jim you bet
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]